bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue au
Musée national d'histoire naturelle de
Paris
nous sommes dans la Grande Galerie de
l'Évolution toute la journée jusqu'à 18h
à l'occasion de la Fête de la Science on
va commencer tout de suite par un jeu
vous avez envie de jouer
j'ai envie de vous entendre est-ce que
bah allez c'est parti générique
[Musique]
je vous le disais pour commencer cette
journée nous allons faire un grand quiz
qui nous a été
concocté par deux célèbres
vidéastes
scientifique que je vous recommande
d'aller voir sur youtube si ce n'est
déjà fait
Valentine de la chaîne science de
comptoir bonjour à tous merci d'être ici
aussi nombreux est-ce que vous êtes
chaud ouais
et Marie de la chaîne la boîte à
curiosité est-ce que vous êtes encore
plus chaud
merci très bien un mot quand même toutes
les deux il faut préciser aussi que vous
êtes sur la chaîne twitch d'Arte
absolument on vient de lancer une
émission avec Arte qui couvre les grands
événements de sciences donc cet été on a
couvert en direct l'arrivée des images
de du James web télescope
et donc dans l'année ponctuellement dès
qu'il y aura des grands événements de
sciences on va les couvrir en direct
avec un envoyé spécial sur le terrain la
prochaine émission c'est samedi prochain
et ça sera sur le retour du bateau Tara
7 non je crois
préciser c'est une émission s'appelle
SCOP et donc c'est sur la chaîne twitch
d'Arte voilà voilà
on passe à notre grand quiz tout de
suite
quel est le thème alors le thème de ce
quiz on va explorer un petit peu les
réponses du vivant face aux changements
climatique c'est à dire comment les
animaux réagissent face à tous ces
bouleversements d'accord combien de
questions comment ça se passe alors nous
avons 10 questions et on va vous
proposer des séries de réponses et vous
allez devoir choisir la réponse qui vous
paraît la plus idoine et vous savez ce
qu'on va faire on va commencer tout de
suite et moi je vais aller avec le
public chercher les réponses et essayer
d'aider le public aussi et parfois on
vous demandera des indices c'est OK
allez c'est parti c'est à vous de gérer
les questions vous êtes prêts on y va
allez alors la première question le
changement climatique a permis à
certaines espèces de petits a se
fabriquer des petits brumisateurs petit
B proliférer en masse petit c'est mieux
communiquer ou petit dés apprendre à
danser la macarena
très utile en société
je me souviens pas du tout de la
chorégraphie
tu en penses quoi
bon à toi tu en penses quoi
la Macarena
non
madame vous pouvez nous aider vous
voulez un indice oui bon un indice s'il
vous plaît un indice alors souvent on
pense que le changement climatique ça
rime avec extinction mais parfois c'est
le contraire c'est un gros indice là
alors là profitez
considérer très très bonne réponse bravo
proliférer
bravo très très bonne réponse alors
comme je disais exactement c'est la
bonne réponse si le changement
climatique souvent ça rime avec
l'extinction des espèces parfois ça peut
profiter à d'autres espèces par exemple
il y a des scientifiques qu'on fait des
études sur les étoiles de mer ils les
ont placé dans des bassins remplis d'eau
de mer et en fait on augmentant la
concentration de dioxyde de carbone et
la température de l'eau ils sont rendus
compte qu'en fait les étoiles de mer se
portaient pas si mal elle se mettait à
grossir à manger davantage et donc à
proliférer davantage et ça c'est un
phénomène qu'on retrouve aussi chez les
Céphalopodes donc depuis le les années
1950 les scientifiques ont constaté
qu'il y avait un vrai boom des
populations de céphalopodes donc les
Céphalopodes c'est tout ce qui est
pieuvre sèches calmar et en fait on se
rend compte que plus les températures
des océans augmentent plus les pieuvres
par exemple s'adaptent et arrivent à
mieux reproduire et c'est des choses
qu'on va constater aussi chez les
insectes par exemple les petits
papillons en Angleterre on s'est rendu
compte que pour trouver de la fraîcheur
les papillons avaient migré un peu plus
vers le nord et en fait ils ont trouvé
des habitats qui leur convenaient encore
mieux et du coup bah pareil on observe
un espèce de boom des papillons dans le
nord de l'Angleterre et par contre
parfois ça peut avoir un effet un peu de
prolifération mais un peu négatif pour
l'être humain par exemple le moustique
pareil vu qu'il fait plus chaud et
parfois plus humide dans certaines
régions du monde et ben le moustique
prolifère davantage et on sait très bien
que le moustique est un vecteur de
maladie donc par exemple le paludisme le
virus Zika le chikungunya et ça c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle pour les humains
tout à fait vous avez peut-être vu
arriver chez vous le moustique tigre ces
dernières années je sais que dans le sud
en tout cas c'est une véritable plaie en
ce moment
je parle d'expérience et ce qui est
marrant avec le moustique en particulier
c'est qu'il est vraiment capable de
s'adapter à son nouvel environnement
particulièrement à Londres on a
maintenant une sous-espèce de moustiques
qui est spécialisée du métro de Londres
donc vous pouvez vous faire piquer par
un moustique qui est spécialiste du
métro c'est un peu la classe il
s'appelle cullex pipians je connais son
nom latin et à propos des céphalopodes
ça me fait penser c'est en Méditerranée
il y a aussi des cas de prolifération de
Méduse les méduses sont particulièrement
à l'aise là-bas et donc on se demande si
ce sera pas l'espèce qui va un peu
dominer le l'écosystème méditerranéen
dans les années à venir voilà je vous le
disais elles sont passionnantes mais
elle parle elle parle question 2
tu sais les femmes
[Rires]
non mais question 2 question 2
alors la question 2 comment les mésanges
s'adapte-t-elle au changement climatique
vous savez les mésanges c'est des petits
oiseaux qu'on voit dans nos campagnes
est-ce que elles font pipi sous la
douche est-ce que elles pondent plutôt
dans l'année
est-ce qu'elle pondent plus tard dans
l'année est-ce qu'elle mange leur
poussin ou question bonus est-ce qu'elle
mette un col roulé
qu'est-ce que tu en penses
je cache la réponse
non mais alors là c'est elle pondent
plus tard dans l'année quel est votre
avis moi j'aurais dit plutôt plutôt donc
c'est la B pour vous d'accord qui est
pour le col roulé lever la main
bon alors on a quelqu'un là qui pense le
col roulé d'autres réponses qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez
là je sais pas entre les deux mais
j'aurais bien réussi
[Musique]
tout le monde est pour plus tôt je suis
comme la dame j'hésite entre les deux ok
on a pas le droit d'hésiter si on a le
droit d'hésiter on a le droit d'hésiter
mais oui on a le droit d'hésiter est-ce
que c'est une bonne réponse n'hésitez
oui c'est toujours une bonne réponse
n'hésitez parce que si on a des idées
préconçues c'est mal c'est bien donc il
faut douter oui c'est bien de douter
donc on peut penser que c'est le col
roulé après tout oui tout à fait
d'accord une dernière réponse moi je
pense que j'aurais mangé les poussins
est-ce qu'on peut enfermer monsieur tout
de suite
est-ce qu'on peut avoir quelqu'un avec
une camisole s'il vous plaît
un peu psychopathe c'est plutôt plutôt
bon alors on va chercher la réponse
dites-nous il y a un grand suspense
plutôt plus tard
quelle est la bonne réponse alors il y a
beaucoup de plutôt il y a pas de Mickey
c'est un peu triste mais effectivement
elle pondent plutôt dans l'année parce
qu'en fait il fait plus chaud plutôt
dans l'année et du coup elle se elle
s'accorde sur les températures pour
pouvoir pondre et c'est très pratique
parce qu'en fait comme ça elle s'accorde
aussi avec les dates d'éclosion des
insectes donc le moment où il y a le
plus d'insectes ce qui leur permet
d'avoir de la nourriture pour permettre
de faire vivre leur petit et la nature
est quand même bien faite voilà et donc
ça c'est des recherches qui ont été
faites par des chercheurs français
particulièrement Montpellier donc
cocorico et les mésanges sont quand même
vachement belles donc j'ai oublié de
préciser si sur les mésanges
charbonnières voilà des fois que
peut-être que les autres espèces
portent d'école rouler on ne sait pas
est-ce qu'on passe à la troisième
question on peut ok allez troisième
question on peut déterminer l'état du
réchauffement des océans en observant
petit à la couleur du phytoplancton par
satellite petit B la migration des
mouettes petit C les étoiles petits dés
les harengs qui pètent
alors on se concentre on réfléchit une
petite idée
la réponse a la couleur du Phyto
plancton la migration des mouettes la
migration des mouettes
peut-être là et la B
les deux les deux on a le droit à
plusieurs réponses sur celle-ci ou pas
bof bof ok d'accord ah je pense vous
vous dites le Phyto aussi phytoplancton
là on a une majorité de a pour le moment
vous dites là
toi aussi mais attendez laisser leur
réponse
la a très bien jeune homme ah aussi bon
on a beaucoup de réponses à est-ce qu'on
peut avoir la bonne c'est la bonne
réponse on peut s'applaudir
quand même
[Applaudissements]
tout à fait la réponse a alors en fait
il y a une équipe de chercheurs
américains qui s'est rendu compte qu'en
fait on pouvait trouver la signature du
changement climatique en observant le
phytoplancton depuis l'espace donc en
fait depuis l'espace on peut observer
dans l'océan les voilà faut bien
regarder l'image en fait le
phytoplancton il va faire des espèces de
masse colorées bleus et verte en
fonction de sa concentration de
chlorophylle et en fait plus les océans
vont augmenter en température plus les
couleurs en fait vont être concentrées
en chlorophylle et donc on va avoir des
nuances beaucoup plus fortes de bleu et
de vert et donc même si c'est très très
joli c'est pas forcément une bonne
nouvelle voilà est-ce que juste tu
pourrais nous parler des harengs qui
pètent
il faut assumer il faut assumer vos
questions quand même les scientifiques
se sont rendus compte que pour
communiquer les harengs pétaient sous
l'eau donc ils mettent un peu de gaz
dans leur anus et en le relâchant en
fait ils font des petits bulles d'air et
ça permet de
de préciser si c'est vrai ou pas donc ce
que tu viens de nous dire c'est tout à
fait exact c'est une vraie info je vous
invite à regarder ça de plus près et
être curieux sur les pets et Aaron parce
que c'est une sacrée histoire très
intéressante question suivante oui
question suivante vite vite quelle
visiteur inhabituel a-t-on croisé en mer
Méditerranée récemment est-ce qu'il
s'agit d'un hippocampe moucheté
de BHL sur un yacht
d'un requin-baleine ou du bateau Tara la
goélette qu'on salue et qu'on ira voir
en vrai sur Arte prochain dimanche
samedi dimanche prochain
alors des idées alors quelle visiteur
inhabituel à ton croisé en mer
Méditerranée récemment un hippocampe BHL
un requin-baleine ou le bateau Tara vous
vous savez on peut peut-être vous nous
mettez des questions c'est pas BHL c'est
quoi comme genre d'espèces avec un col
blanc oui oui c'est c'est le genre
amateur de tarte d'accord bon alors à
votre avis pour moi c'est la réponse
c'est de regarder un requin baleine
peut-être la a un hippocampe jeune homme
requin-baleine
un BHL sur
[Musique]
comme quoi vous poser des questions
pièges qui ne sont pas forcément
comprises par tout le monde c'est une
question de génération est-ce que tu
sais ce qu'est un BHL
pas vraiment d'accord alors je crois que
on va attendre la fin pour avoir la
bonne réponse monsieur un requin-baleine
un requin-baleine mademoiselle rien
on a rien rien non on a rien du tout
madame
hippocampe un hippocampe moucheté
vous êtes aussi requin le requin il est
moucheté aussi le requin baleine non un
peu oui je crois qu'il est un peu
moucheté oui
[Rires]
est-ce qu'on pourra avoir quelqu'un qui
parlerait espagnol
alors Monsieur moi je dirais un requin
baleine un requin on a une majorité de
requins baleines non
monsieur on va dire la même en français
bon alors on va chercher la bonne
réponse on a une très nette majorité de
requins baleine on a un BHL on a deux ou
trois fois hippocampe
et un Tara alors la réponse était un
requin-baleine félicitations bravo bravo
bravo bravo très belle animal alors il y
avait des réponses pièges en fait BHL
c'est un philosophe français qui aime
bien aller sur des yachts donc du coup
c'est pas si extraordinaire que ça mais
c'est quand même une bonne réponse que
tu as fait parce qu'on en trouve en
Méditerranée de ces espèces là donc
bravo donc le requin-baleine c'est assez
extraordinaire d'en voir en Méditerranée
pas de voir des requins en général parce
que il y a 40 espèces de requins qu'on
trouve en Méditerranée mais le
requin-baleine il est un féodé aux eaux
plus chaudes aux autres tropicales et
sub tropicales on dit que c'est une
espèce cosmopolite il y en a un peu
partout mais là il a tendance comme pas
vu aussi avec les mésanges à remonter
légèrement et alors ce qui est
particulier c'est qu'on en a vu un au
large de Nice il y a pas longtemps et
quand je dis un c'est un pilote
d'hélicoptère qui a vu un truc un peu
bizarre par terre il s'est dit oh mais
enfin par terre dans l'eau parce que
voilà et il s'est dit ah mais qu'est-ce
que c'est que ça et alors il a pas pris
de photos mais d'après sa description a
priori il s'agirait d'un requin baleine
qu'on a vu en Méditerranée donc ça c'est
ce que je vous dis ça remonte à
septembre donc c'est vraiment il y a pas
longtemps et c'est la deuxième
occurrence de ce requin en Méditerranée
le premier avait été trouvé au large de
la Turquie et on pense qu'il serait
passé par la mer Rouge en fait via le
canal de Suez pour arriver en
Méditerranée donc c'est assez
impressionnant et on pense qu'avec le
réchauffement climatique le changement
climatique pardon il y aurait de plus en
plus d'espèces chaudes qui remontrait
comme ça et ça pose un problème
particulièrement en Méditerranée parce
qu'en fait comme plus il fait chaud plus
les espèces se déplacent haut en
latitude pour avoir des eaux plus à une
température qui leur conviennent le truc
c'est que la Méditerranée n'est pas
infinie
ça bloque en haut et donc comment elles
vont faire quand elles vont arriver tout
au nord et que les eaux vont continuer à
se réchauffer ça c'est un phénomène qui
a été baptisé par les chercheurs par un
phénomène cul-de-sac et ça se dit en
anglais c'est vraiment que le sac et
donc c'est vraiment dommage pour les
espèces endémiques de Méditerranée parce
que on sait pas trop ce qu'elles vont
devenir avec le réchauffement climatique
et ça me fait penser à il y a des
cachalots en Méditerranée et ça fait pas
longtemps qu'on le qu'on le sait et
c'est des espèces qui ne migrent plus et
je sais qu'il y a des scientifiques cet
été qui sont partis en expédition pour
essayer de mieux comprendre comment ils
étaient arrivés là et pourquoi
aujourd'hui migrent plus donc c'est très
stylé je précise juste en passant
l'hippocampe mouchetée il y en a en
Méditerranée aussi et particulièrement
autour de l'étang de tôt on parlait de
cette tout à l'heure donc voilà donc
c'est pas loin et donc effectivement on
en trouve aussi en Méditerranée très
bien merci pour ces précisions
d'ailleurs le requin-baleine totalement
inoffensif si vous le croisez vous
pouvez si vous avez la chance de le
croiser vous baigner avec question
comment s'adapte certains animaux pour
mieux réguler leur température petit à
ils installent des petits climatiseurs
dans leur zone de vie petit B leur
morphologie se modifient pour mieux
réguler leur chaleur petit C il font la
grève de la fin petit dés il perd de
leur poils
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un peu madame je dirais le B le B ou d
il perdent leurs poils
leurs morphologie il se modifie
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez morphologie
morphologie
devant la cuisine
[Musique]
alors toi qu'est-ce que tu en penses
ils installent des petits climatiseurs
et toi
tu souffles tu lui as soufflé quoi dans
l'oreille
toi tu penses que c'est le B oui
d'accord allez encore quelques réponses
le B toi aussi le B et toi
moi je dirais ils font la grève de la
fin
on a des humoristes qui sont venus
s'immiscer dans le public qu'en
pensez-vous l'abbé
aussi oh là là
elles sont peut-être trop elle est trop
facile celle-ci
[Musique]
on attend vos réponses votre réponse ça
vous et bien c'est la réponse B et bravo
vous êtes trop fort vous êtes forts à
chaque fois trop fort alors
effectivement
attendez on a une petite intervention là
quand même
de la fin pourquoi pas oui bah oui c'est
vrai
d'accord mais c'est la B mais c'est la B
mais merci Monsieur
alors oui il y a des scientifiques qui
ont découvert que chez les animaux donc
les endothermes je vais vous expliquer
ce que c'est qu'un endotherme c'est les
animaux qui produisent eux-mêmes leurs
propres chaleurs comme vous et moi et à
l'inverse on a les ectothermes qui sont
comme les serpents à sang-froid et en
fait chez les endothermes on a remarqué
que certaines espèces
on constate qu'il y a des modifications
dans la morphologie et particulièrement
chez les oiseaux au niveau de leur bec
sur les 150 dernières années on a
constaté que chez certaines espèces de
perroquets la taille du bec avait
augmenté entre 4 et 10%. pourquoi parce
qu'en fait les oiseaux leur sang passent
directement dans leur bec et pour se
rafraîchir par exemple chez les toucans
on a constaté que les toucans trempaient
leur bec dans de l'eau fraîche et comme
ça le sang circule dans le bec se
refroidit et ensuite se diffuse pour
refroidir le corps de l'animal et il est
capable de se refroidir de 10 degrés en
deux minutes donc un système super
efficace et donc bah voilà le bec chez
les animaux gros chez les oiseaux
grossis petit à petit mais c'est pas
propre qu'aux oiseaux chez certains
mammifères chez les musaraignes chez les
chauves-souris on a constaté aussi que
leurs pattes lorsque ou surtout leurs
oreilles étaient en train de grandir
pour mieux répartir la chaleur et se
refroidir correctement voilà est-ce que
c'est valable chez l'humain aussi on va
voir de plus en plus grosses doit être
voilà si il fait très chaud sur Terre on
nous les humains allons avoir de très
grandes oreilles pour se refroidir comme
pour les éléphants
changer leur capacités à se nourrir
peut-être c'est une bonne question
peut-être bien j'imagine que forcément
c'est un impact mais et bien je j'irai
chercher la réponse merci pour cette
question mais je pense que oui forcément
ça a un impact et les chercheurs doivent
travailler dessus j'imagine aussi
très bien question suivante question
numéro 6
le changement climatique encore lui il
est partout à un effet surprenant sur
les tortues les tortues lequel alors on
parle de tortue marine dans l'occurrence
est-ce qu'il retarde leur maturité
sexuelle et en fait d'éternel
adolescents est-ce qu'il multiplie le
nombre de femelles
est-ce qu'il les transforme en ninja qui
mange de la pizza ou est-ce qu'il les
rend végan
alors on va essayer d'obtenir une
réponse je sais pas si on est dans le
même monde qu'est-ce que tu en penses
là je suis un peu
genre de cornichon
c'est un gros délire c'était là je suis
sur l'espace de l'Inserm tu te promènes
où dans quel univers
est-ce que ça t'intéresse les tortues si
je te pose une question est-ce que tu
peux faire deux choses en même temps oui
normalement alors ok écoute bien le
changement climatique a un effet
surprenant sur les tortues lequel il
retarde leur maturité sexuelle et on
fait d'éternel des adolescents il
multiplie le nombre de femelles il les
transforme en ninja il les rend vegan
oui alors je pense que c'est la
multiplie le nombre de femelles bon je
reviens vers toi tout à l'heure un bonne
promenade je vais demander à d'autres
personnes merci alors quand on
pensez-vous
je dirais laver aussi la B très bien on
va aller chercher elle avait aussi
l'abeille multiplie le nombre de
femelles
la baie
pour moi il est allergique au gluten je
suis désolé c'est la réponse
on demande confirmation aux enfants
qu'en penses-tu
regarde tu sais pas et toi
[Musique]
pourquoi pas
madame ben moi je vais dire il retarde
le marteau sexuel ok là
pour moi c'est la baie pour vous c'est
la baie
la bonne réponse et bien c'était la baie
effectivement vous êtes très très fort
trop fort
oui donc effectivement le changement
climatique multiplie le nombre de
femelles chez les tortues alors là en
l'occurrence l'étude que j'ai regardé
c'était chez les tortues vertes tortues
marines donc que vous voyez ici est-ce
qu'il se passe en fait chez les reptiles
et chez aussi certains oiseaux c'est que
c'est la température d'incubation de
l'oeuf qui va influer sur le sexe donc
si l'oeuf est si l'oeuf est un cubé dans
une température dans du sable à 30
degrés on va dire ça va faire des
femelles si c'est du Sable à 20 degrés
ça va faire des mâles donc ça c'est un
système qui marche très bien d'habitude
sauf patatras quand le climat est
dérégulé et à ce moment-là ce qui se
passe donc là en l'occurrence c'était en
Australie ils ont remarqué sur une plage
que il pouvait y avoir jusqu'à 99% de
femelles dans la population alors que
d'habitude et dans des zones un peu plus
froides ils sont autour de tatata 65% de
femelles et donc ça ça pose plein de
problèmes parce qu'ils se disent comment
les populations vont pouvoir se
reproduire s'il y a plus que des
femelles
quelle stratégie ils vont pouvoir mettre
en place donc ça je n'ai pas de réponse
à cette question mais il faut savoir que
la température pivot pour cette espèce à
cet endroit là c'est 27 à 29 degrés ça
veut dire que assez température là on
fait autant de mal que de femelle et
c'est très sensible vous montez d'un
degré au-dessus et vous avez 80 % de
femelle donc c'est ultra sensible donc
c'est ça qui est un peu dommage et donc
on sait pas ce que ça va faire et on a
un peu inquiet quand même voilà bonne
journée est-ce qu'on peut se permettre
de vous poser une question enfin
Monsieur voudrait vous poser une
question
on peut jouer sur le le sexe alors sur
les accuse dans avec les incubateurs on
peut jouer sur le sexe on peut sans
doute oui mais à ce moment là c'est plus
enfin on aide l'espèce donc c'est ça
peut aider effectivement mais on est
dans un dans un contexte où c'est pas
juste une petite perturbation on peut
les aider à passer l'hiver là c'est
vraiment ça va être comme ça chaque
année donc est-ce qu'on décide vraiment
de prendre ça en charge ou pas pour les
tortues
exactement mais effectivement on va
peut-être falloir faire quelque chose
quand même pour ces pauvres tortues
vertes
on passe à la question suivante le
mélomis rubikola et le crapaud doré sont
deux espèces qui petit à ont été élu les
plus belles gosses de l'univers petit B
ont migré vers le Nord pour fuir la
chaleur petit C se retrouve dans le
monde de d'Harry Potter ou petit dés ont
été déclarés et teintes à cause du
changement climatique oh là là il y a un
premier nom que je connais pas du tout
c'est quoi le mélomis rubikola c'est un
tout petit mammifère un petit rongeur
qui ressemble un peu à une musaraigne
d'accord donc lui et le crapaud doré
sont les deux espèces qui qui madame je
vois que vous vous concentrez vous
diriez quoi
migré vers le nord pourquoi pas
moi je vois bien le mélomis rubicola
migré vers le nord avec ces petites
pâtes
[Musique]
c'est dur comme question
allez vas-y lance-toi la D ont été
déclarés éteintes
ont été élus les plus belles
la D aussi est un moi je pense également
que ces espèces sont éteintes à cause du
changement climatique
on va voir je sais pas vous devez avoir
la bonne réponse peut-être
c'est
la
version on va revenir vers vous
alors alors alors qui a envie de
répondre alors en pensez vous la baie
vous vous dites migration vers le nord
on n'hésite pas mal entre la baie allez
c'est vous qui allez nous donner la
bonne réponse la dater déclaré éteinte
alors on se retrouve vers vous pour nous
donner la bonne réponse
c'est la réponse d donc c'est le mélomis
bravo pardon
[Applaudissements]
j'arrive pas à applaudir
la réponse d parce que
c'est la réalité aussi une des réponses
du vivant face à ces bouleversements
climatiques c'est aussi l'extinction des
espèces et donc comme exemple le mélomis
rubikola qui a un petit rongeur qui
était endémique qui ne vivait que sur
l'île sur une île au large de
l'Australie sur un espèce une île mais
pas très haute au dessus du niveau de la
mer 3 mètres environ et en fait avec le
niveau de la mer qui a augmenté il y a
eu beaucoup de inondations et ce petit
mammifère n'a pas survécu et a disparu
il a été déclaré état officiellement en
2016 et la première espèce à avoir été
déclarée éteinte officiellement à cause
du changement climatique c'est celui que
vous voyez sur la photo le crapaud doré
qui était une espèce endémique des
forêts du Costa Rica et à cause de
plusieurs épisodes de sécheresse à
répétition et bien il y a eu un espace
d'épisodes de mycose des maladies des
champignons qui sont installés sur les
petits crapauds et ça a décimé
absolument toutes les populations et
donc ça en 2001 ça a été la première
espèce où on s'est dit au niveau mondial
là le bouleversement climatique a causé
la disparition d'une espèce animale
voilà
on estime qu'il y a 9 % de tout le
vivant qui est menacé par ces
changements là donc
mauvaise nouvelle
question suivante oui
oui non je pense juste la bonne nouvelle
dans tout ça c'est que ça fera plus
d'espèces derrière nous non non non
d'espèces ici précisément il faut il y a
d'ailleurs une pièce qui est réservée
aux espèces disparues et il faut pas y
toucher
alors question suivante maintenant on va
parler des saumons comment les saumons
répondent-ils au changement climatique
est-ce qu'il répond pas wesh frérot bien
ou bien comme tout le monde
est-ce que il ne migre plus au même
endroit est-ce que il migre plus tôt
dans l'année
est-ce qu'il s'étale sur des bagels par
dessus une couche de fromage frais avec
des petites tranches d'avocat au dessus
il peut y avoir un petit piège le petit
piège bon bah alors on pourrait
considérer est-ce que vous pensez que ça
pourrait être la a
fresh frérot bien ou bien non je pense
pas non c'est pas ça est-ce que vous
pensez que ça pourrait être la D
il s'étale sur des bagels je pense pas
non plus la baie à mon avis il ne migre
plus au même endroit ça voudrait dire
qu'il pleurait plus reproduire ça serait
triste donc plutôt lasser quand même
mais plutôt plutôt dans l'année allez
c'est parti pour lacet
plutôt dans l'année qu'en penses-tu
moi aussi je la saisie
[Musique]
au même endroit moi je suis pour la C
aussi la C je vais tenter laver aussi la
baie b c ça se partage monsieur
la
bellacée
et vous lassez
elle pense B alors vous vous pensez
c'est mais avec avec une réserve en suis
pas sûrement
peut-être que vous avez toutes les deux
raisons c'est pas pourquoi vous vous
pensez plutôt
[Musique]
mais j'ai presque j'ai l'impression
d'avoir déjà entendu ça mais honnêtement
j'ai aucune source fiable et c'est
vraiment juste au fond de la mémoire
j'ai envie
qu'il y avait un petit piège je crois
donc est-ce qu'on peut avoir là où les
bonnes réponses la réponse c'est que
vous avez toutes les deux raisons c'est
l'abbé et lacets
[Applaudissements]
et pas seulement monsieur aussi et
finalement tout le monde a raison tout
le monde a raison c'est pas beau ça
quand même
que l'amour ici donc effectivement donc
B et C alors d'abord je vais parler du C
donc immigre plutôt dans l'année parce
que comme beaucoup d'espèces en fait il
se cale sur la température des eaux et
du coup ils vont migrer plutôt donc là
il y a une étude qui a été faite sur le
saumon rose à bosse qui vit dans la en
Alaska donc dans le Pacifique et les
chercheurs se sont rendus compte qu'il
migraient deux semaines plus tôt en 40
ans donc c'est énorme quand même deux
semaines
donc voilà pour ça et ensuite il Migros
aussi plus haut en latitude donc en
l'occurrence j'ai vu ça sur une espèce
de saumon atlantique donc de l'autre
côté de du monde et donc c'est on voit
sur la carte d'ailleurs là donc les
trajets de migration et on voit que ceux
qui sont déjà haut en latitude donc vers
le nord ils sont plutôt bien mais ceux
qui sont vers le sud et notamment en
Irlande immigre très très haut et donc
ils se disent que plus le changement
climatique va plus en fait leur terrain
de migration sont plus hauts et donc lui
ils vont faire de trajet donc plus ils
vont se fatiguer en fait donc ils savent
pas les chercheurs si ça va être très
bénéfique pour le saumon moi ce que j'en
pense c'est qu'ils vont être plus
musclés après et du coup ils auront une
chair de meilleure qualité
voilà non en vrai c'est dramatique tout
ce qui se passe c'est terrible qu'est-ce
que je voulais dire alors oui c'est tout
voilà
on passe à la 9e
question sur le corail avant dernière
question alors à cause du changement
climatique les coraux petit tas font des
fleurs B blanchissent c'est son
comestibles et particulièrement bon en
grattant ou des sons stériles
[Musique]
elle avait tu dirais la paix blanchisse
une petite est-ce que je peux te poser
une petite question le corail c'est quoi
ton avis c'est des plantes dans l'eau
c'est des plantes c'est un animal
c'est vivant ah ça c'est vivant c'est
plutôt un animal le corail alors toi tu
réponds blanchissent mademoiselle
du courage
merci beaucoup
moi j'aurais dit la baie blanche
hmm
je sais pas je sais plus tu sais plus tu
hésite à mettre un peu envie de répondre
[Musique]
laquelle
pourquoi pas
qu'en penses-tu la paix blanche
facile comment ça vous savez pas
stérile voilà j'hésite entre les deux
stérile aussi
je pense BD aussi ça fait BD ça fait BD
ça fait BD
la bonne réponse est la B bravo nous
avons très très fort aujourd'hui
alors on a constaté que l'augmentation
des températures des océans causait ce
qu'on appelle le blanchissement des
coraux pour faire un très gros raccourci
leur mort et aujourd'hui on se rend pas
compte mais le corail même s'il ne
couvre que 0,1% de toute la surface des
océans il abrite un quart de toutes les
la vitesse du poisson de poisson au
monde et c'est énorme donc la perte des
coraux serait absolument catastrophique
pour les océans tout en sachant que les
coraux sont aussi utiles aux êtres
humains que ça soit pour de la pêche
locale un peu de tourisme donc la perte
des coraux ça serait une catastrophe au
niveau des espèces mais aussi pour les
humains à qui ça permet de vivre donc au
niveau économique social et sanitaire ça
pourrait être compliqué parce que si les
barrières de corail de de coraux font
barrière naturelle anti-inondation ça
freine les vagues ça peut être utile
aussi donc voilà mauvaise nouvelle pour
le corail mais petite question ici quand
même ah bah oui
du corail est-ce que c'est l'animal qui
blanchit ou c'est l'enveloppe le corail
c'est un peu difficile à expliquer
puisque c'est un peu bizarre comme
animal mais en gros c'est une colonie de
polypes qui se loge dans un squelette de
calcaire et donc en fait le blanchiment
c'est quand ces petites polypes meurent
et du coup on ne voit que le résidu de
squelette de quelqu'un c'est pour ça que
c'est blanc et en fait c'est une petite
TAlgue qui est à l'intérieur
qui vivent en osmose et qui s'en vont
parce qu'il fait trop chaud donc ces
algues qui sont colorés disparaissent
voilà il ne reste que le squelette blanc
voilà on passe à la dernière question
Valentine dernière question on se
concentre attention attention lequel de
ces facteurs impacte le plus le vivant
est-ce que c'est une augmentation de la
température moyenne annuelle attention
accrochez-vous bien des pics de chaleur
plus intenses par exemple grosse
canicule PAF
la sortie d'une vidéo de la boîte à
curiosité abonnez-vous sur Youtube ou
moi même qu'il ai-je des cailloux
alors en fait c'est pas facile du tout
j'hésite entre les deux dernières moi
qu'est-ce que vous pensez qu'en
pensez-vous alors lequel de ces facteurs
impactent le plus le vivant une
augmentation de la température moyenne
annuelle des pics de chaleur plus
intenses la sortie d'une vidéo de la
boîte à curiosité ou Valentine qui lèche
des cailloux je dirais là à une
augmentation de la température moyenne
monsieur
vous dites là a aussi jeune homme
gérer la B la B
d'accord très bien une majorité de a on
a un petit peu de B je dirais B aussi
vous diriez B hein on commence à se
rapprocher madame
j'hésite entre A et ouais mais vous avez
raison d'hésiter on est là pour ça alors
allez alors allez entre les deux si vous
aviez un petit choix à faire
augmentation de la température moyenne
des piques de chaleur plus intense
peut-être à d'accord très bien oui là
aussi vous c'est clair
une des deux une des deux entre A et B
ok d'accord
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est pas la réponse la plus évidente
comme ça parce qu'on est en temps
tellement parlé de hausse moyenne des
températures exactement alors la
question est un peu piège en quelque
sorte parce que je parlais d'impacter le
vivant mais là on parle vraiment de
mortalité à des endroits locaux et donc
il y a des chercheurs qui sont amusés
donc c'était des chercheurs norvégiens
qui sont mis en 2020 à prendre en compte
536 espèces et à regarder comment enfin
où est le vivait où elle mourait et en
fonction de quel facteur de Lisa des
facteurs environnementaux notamment de
température et il s'est rendu compte que
ce qu'il y avait le plus d'effets sur la
mortalité locale des espèces animales et
végétales donc plante et animaux
confondues c'était non pas
l'augmentation annuelle de la
température mais les gros pics de
chaleur donc les gros pics comme on a pu
avoir cet été enfin c'est un très long
pic quand même mais donc ça c'est ce qui
impact en plus c'est ce qui cause le
plus de mortalité et voilà et donc je
m'y attendais pas du tout non plus
merci on va développer ce thème avec
l'inrae cet après-midi dans une émission
qui aura lieu à 16h ici voilà on va
conclure ce quiz d'abord en
applaudissant le public
bravo qui a été
excellent quand même la plupart des
questions ont trouvé de bonnes réponses
dans le public
Valentine et Marie on vous retrouve sur
vos chaînes respectives la boîte à
curiosité et j'allais dire science de
compteur j'allais dire bref de comptoir
si on se le comptoir et surtout votre
actualité c'est la chaîne twitch Darty
SCOP l'émission SCOP l'émission le
prochain rendez-vous c'est samedi
prochain le week-end prochain le
week-end prochain le 15 octobre sur la
chaîne twitch Darte donc pour le retour
de Tara la goélette qui a regardé le
microbiome donc tout le plancton et
compagnie qu'on trouve dans les océans
très bien et bien on vous remercie merci
beaucoup merci de les applaudir merci à
tous
ce quiz est terminé
générique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]